everybody um quick little video we're
actually in the middle of a noir day
which was an opportunity for me to give
a three hour keynote to my organization
here at vaynermedia the 195 employees
and talk about where we're going and
what we're doing as a company and kind
of get everybody in the same page it was
awesome and now we're kind of having a
party and everybody's drinking fine wine
and playing games and board games and
getting together and interacting a lot
of people meeting each other we have a
lot of new employees and felt very
compelled to make a video I'm on the
video kick as you guys know I've been
missing you guys and so here's what I
want to talk about I think people have
it reversed the one two threes I think
the one two threes are reversed for so
many people I think a lot of people
think about their businesses as
employees car customers and potential
customers and I do believe that most
people are in hunting mode at all times
and they're looking for new business
where do I get new customers how to get
new people to buy wine for me how do I
get people to buy their home for me get
me a new person to buy my software or
the product I'm selling or read my blog
it's new new new new new new customer
number one number two current customers
and oftentimes number three employees
and I think it's time people flip the
three to one after spending more time
today that just another probably the
600th reminder I've had this week that
we cannot win jack crap unless the
culture and the people in this building
fight for each other and we're a
cohesive unit I truly believe that the
reason I've had a lot of success in my
careers in different businesses and very
much on our way with this one is the
team first employees number one not
number three uh and then after that I
want to say employees again employees
after that current customers they tend
to stay in number two and then in the
last place is new business I just think
people are waiting too infatuated with
new business they've got to flip the
employees are an afterthought and
expense an overhead and I just think
you've got it [ __ ] up if that's the
way you think about it if you care about
your team and you empower them and you
create the culture and you force them to
play nice with each other and that's a
key creating that culture where they
play nice with each other and they
respect each other and communicate with
each other that's the game reverse the
one two threes and I think they'll see
an impact on your business
just one man's POV